the Joe Rogan experience well most of
them are good this is a thing I was I
was just getting into with a friend of
mine we're talking about people and
their motivation for getting into fights
and I was like or for getting into
fighting and I was like I go some of it
is not good man some of the motivation
it's just but what happens once you
become a fighter like you can you can
sort of transcend what your initial
motivation was like a lot of people they
got motivated into fighting because of
abuse they were picked on they were
bullied or maybe even abuse at home or
you know father beat them or something
like that and then they became this
angry mean person and want to get back
in the world but through martial arts
you could transcend that and find peace
mhm and this is something that I think
is it's it's needs to be discussed more
it needs to be talked more because
people don't they don't hear it too much
from the fighters perspective because
fighters don't really express these
ideas that much they just try to win and
you know and kick ass and do their best
but you can find peace through combat
you really can you can find a better
version of yourself by getting through
things that are even more difficult than
the childhood that you want mm-hmm and
you're gonna eat a lot of humble pie
yeah especially when you start yes and
it's a bitter taste yeah I always tell
people you think George and Pierre
didn't get killed in practice when he
was a white belt he thinks he started
black belt know right like everybody
that he got killed we all got killed
everyone our way to black belt now you
see a black belt he rarely ever gets put
in a bad position but what what you
think he started like this he's suffered
[Applause]